send we also want to collect mue here we
discussed a little bit about who
everybody's favorite subject is aliens
we all want to know he doesn't love the
aliens everyone doesn't love him now
Troy uh is a bit of a conspiracy guy
when it comes to aliens I'm talking a
troy lesson ever do I have since talked
about it and you want to put more there
so you can least the dark eyes that
surrounds me I just like I just I have
stuff written down that's all okay okay
because if you remember last time we
wait so if it's written down that means
you're not really carrying this
knowledge well here even you I just want
to have it at my fingertips so we could
discuss it last time I was amused
because you as a renowned physicist
we're having a debate with a guy who
just rolled in here having watched a
bunch of episodes of ancient aliens my
guys work I'm cool with people you know
it's a free country and if we should
think and who would say what you want
rather that's that's why we know we live
in a free country right so and I'm
intrigued when people feel passionately
about these topics then I wonder maybe
they're missing some bit of critical
thinking that I could then assist Troy
what do you think yeah but you know
yours Jana Mike you gotta remember yeah
alright you're a facts guy so I made
sure I had a lot of facts for you laid
out just so you know there wasn't any
question of that this is just made up
and just hearsay which is just to be
clear I rarely talk about facts in that
context because what matters more than
facts are ideas that may be derived from
them and you could there could be a
measurement that's made and it's a fact
that that measurement was made but the
measurement itself could be flawed it is
a fact that you were telling me you were
abducted that doesn't make what you're
saying true that is true okay so that's
why it was in fact I need facts facts
facts and I don't it's not really about
facts well it is a fact that you can
arrive nine I diversity of information
it's a fact you know 99.9 percent rafita
light but uh a percent way to bring it
fried came Troy what do you guys know
there was just a lot of information
available about past presidents that
have talked about it things
organizations that have been set up by
leaders of the country if you ever want
to go out what's your whatever yes yeah
what's your question area you want to
present well the question is there's
been a lot of
structures found on the moon and on Mars
that good would be you know I guess
linked to ancient some sort of ancient
civilization ruptures you can't explain
right that's entirely saying we're
linking them to ancient civilizations
you need to distinguish oh here's here's
a structure I don't know how it got
there if it is a structure at all that's
really the end of the conversation after
that however you can make stuff up you
could say it's probably ancient aliens
that are on the moon that can breathe
the vacuum of space or whatever go ahead
and that can make a really cool movie
but just because it's something you
can't explain
doesn't mean aliens did it what I'm
saying could be dragon what's the Mars
one denied Oh Dahlia that's all I'm
saying
and so so when people say I saw a UFO it
must have been aliens well what is the
you stand for I've said there's a
YouTube video meets multiple YouTube
videos videos of me saying it the U
stands for unidentified right so you're
looking at a light in the sky and you
don't know what it is the UFO period and
be the act of you admitting you don't
know what it is
preclude you from then saying it's
therefore must be aliens visit
intelligent aliens visiting and
observing us from another planet can I
ask you this I stopped at the period do
you not if they land and you can drag
one into town square we're good we're
good to go
my body go for it I'm gonna be good
don't you think they like this one
question I have a UFOs is when airline
pilots those guys know a lot about the
aerodynamics and fly and when they see
things that they don't understand right
when they see the Goodman AC cannot
explain yes when they see craft moving
in a way that they when they see
something they obviously lights or
sometimes they've seen them closer
though and there's - they've seen well
Dennis
I just eyewitness testimony bill I mean
when two pilots see something move a
certain way that's the only thing that
makes me question because those guys
understand hey this is a military test
craft that you and I might think they
don't understand right period and you
don't work in theories well no I can no
no it would be a hypothesis - okay I
promise this is an idea that's not yet
tested and doesn't we don't know if it
works yet so let's keep trying right so
if so if they don't know what it is they
don't notice now if you want to
hypothesize that it's intelligent aliens
visiting us in some fine get me more
data to support that hypothesis do you
have lunch I could use I mean I have a
lot of quotes and a lot of information
from different astronauts people
involved in military get I didn't
understand a first CIA director ever had
mentioned that there's aliens Ronald
Reagan has gone on had one stop stop why
I'm sorry but he has evidence that
they're aliens that someone of high rank
says so are you using stone painting of
statements made by people as evidence
for the existence of intelligent aliens
from outer space that visited earth
because we've known forever that
eyewitness testimony however high it is
in the court of law is the lowest form
of evidence in the court of science
everybody today has a video camera
everybody we have video footage of buses
tumbling in tornadoes at a time where go
back in time if you saw a bus tumbling
or you can say let me run home and get
Mike Mike Mike Mike recording device and
come back and film is no you get your
ass out of there because you don't want
to die everybody has a video camera we
have video footage of the rarest stuff
there ever was because everybody is
everywhere equipped to do so where is
the footage of people getting abducted
where is the footage of encounters with
aliens we're at and then once we have
that footage if you're that close to
them hit them over the head and drag
them into the where if they have a head
drag them into the square Vande you're
good and then there's no you don't have
to try to fight anybody to get there
believe what you saw you have evidence
that would work in the court of science
and right now nothing you are telling me
would survive that scrutiny
you